hey 42 here this video is sponsored by
Squarespace Squarespace is to you all in
one platform to build a beautiful online
presence and run your business eggs meat
cheese broccoli all these foods contain
a healthy dose of protein you probably
have a rough idea of what proteins are
and that they have something to do with
repairing muscle but what is a protein
exactly a protein is a string of amino
acids bound together by a covalent
chemical bond called a peptide bond but
what makes proteins so incredibly useful
is their unimaginable complexity
proteins are like tiny machines that
live in your body and they can form an
infinite number of shapes the vast array
of shaped proteins can form makes these
tiny machines Jack's of all trade for
example proteins move your body
structural proteins such as Kinison
Dinan and myosin can contract and relax
to exert kinetic forces and when
millions of proteins do this together
your muscles move one of the most common
forms that proteins become or fold into
in your body is enzymes enzymes are no
more than special proteins that catalyze
chemical reactions in your body you have
lots of different kinds of enzymes some
digest your food offers turn starch into
sugars each enzyme is highly specialized
and can only do one specific job that it
has been constructed for proteins can
also replicate your DNA and repair
damaged DNA proteins form a number of
different DNA replication enzymes that
each serve a specialized function for
example helicase enzymes unwind your DNA
ready for replication
whereas polymerase enzymes are
specifically responsible for
proofreading the replicated DNA and
correcting any errors like repairing
corrupted bites on a computer's hard
drive there are many of us that each
perform their own specialized yet highly
complex
to make more of you based on your unique
DNA template and they also repair bits
of you when you break according to that
very same template but for all the good
that proteins do they can also kill you
Botox is a protein it works by blocking
nerve signals from reaching your facial
muscles at the injection sites and so
without any incoming instructions the
muscles simply go dead and relax which
smoothes out wrinkles but Botox also
happens to be the most lethal toxin
known to man when use incorrectly or by
someone who doesn't know what they're
doing it can kill easily in fact one
gram of Botox is enough to kill 8.3
million people that means it would take
just 50 grams to kill every person on
the planet but what if we could design
new proteins that could be introduced to
our bodies to perform specific tasks
perhaps life-saving tasks in nature
proteins begin life our strands of amino
acids and they fold themselves into
complex shapes only once folded into a
very specific shape can they perform the
tasks that they are intended for exactly
how a string of amino acids will fold is
determined by the sequence in which the
amino acids are initially joined
together theoretically if scientists
could create sequences that fold to form
stable proteins that could let's say
target and destroy cancer cells in the
human body
this would of course be an immense
breakthrough and that's exactly what
some companies and universities have
been attempting to do for the past few
decades the issue is that there are
unlimited combinations of sequences and
those folded protein designs and finding
out how existing proteins are formed
never mind how to design custom proteins
from scratch is unbelievably difficult
the way that researchers have been
tackling this monolith of a
so fall is with brute force by using
computers to simulate endless
combinations of protein folds they can
slowly build a picture of how specific
amino acid sequences and therefore
specific folds create different protein
structures and what jobs they will
ultimately perform in the body you may
have heard of folding at home it started
in 2000 at Stanford University with the
ambitious goal to create one of the
world's largest distributed
supercomputers to simulate protein folds
24 hours a day on millions of computers
around the world and Sunday use all this
data to find miraculous new cures for
cancer Alzheimer's and others by
figuring out how proteins miss fold
sometimes protein folding goes around
proteins can fold incorrectly which
causes diseases such as Alzheimer's but
if science can figure out why some
proteins fold incorrectly they could
potentially prevent it from happening in
the first place if a protein does miss
fold it's usually due simply to the law
of large numbers if you crack enough
eggs eventually you're going to get some
shell in the omelets folding at home
uses an individual's personal computers
to create a worldwide distributed
supercomputer to simulate every single
way an egg can crack ie every way a
protein can fault and over ten plus
years the program has been successful in
helping to research a number of
life-saving drugs but what if humanity
could take the science of protein
folding one step further and actually
design new proteins to accomplish highly
specific tasks such as killing cancer
cells more powerful computer processes
in recent years has enabled researchers
to experiment with the possibility of
doing exact
that one of the most elusive prizes in
all of medicine is cracking the flu
virus influenza comes in thousands of
different strains and each flu season it
mutates into a whole bunch of entirely
new versions of the flu virus that have
never been seen before this means it
cannot be vaccinated against because a
vaccine has to be designed for one
particular strain you can get the flu
jab each year but that only protects
against the most popular predicted
strains for that particular season by
the following year that vaccine will
have become obsolete scientists have
been scratching their heads for decades
trying to find the holy grail of
medicine a universal flu vaccine which
could be inoculated only once in a
patient and would protect against all
possible future flu viruses with the
help of protein design this enigma may
be closer than ever before to becoming
reality the University of Washington's
Institute for protein design has
recently been awarded an eleven million
dollar grant to develop a universal flu
vaccine
unlike handing your immune system
specific instructions on how to deal
with each and every flu virus currently
out there like current vaccines do the
Washington team are taking a fresh
approach they believe that custom
proteins can be designed from scratch
using computer software called rosetta
which is like AutoCAD for proteins these
custom proteins will be constructed from
nanoparticles and once inoculated in a
patient system they will attach
themselves onto specific cells and
antibodies and act like an add-on or
expansion pack for your immune system
the custom proteins will help your
antibodies to attach to and destroy a
wide range of common antigens that are
found in the vast majority of different
influenza strains think of these
designer proteins as converting your
immune system to a highly
targeted killing machine to a capsule
defense system based on current designs
these synthetic proteins will need to be
readmitted every five years to maintain
effectiveness but if their work proves
successful Washington believe a similar
method could be used to develop designer
protein vaccines for all types of
infectious viruses such as Ebola and HIV
the Washington team say there are
literally thousands of possible
applications for synthetic designer
proteins in theory they could be
engineered to perform any task inside
the body from fighting viruses to
enhancing everyday bodily functions one
popular idea protein designers have put
forward as a potential use of the
technology in the very near future is to
relieve celiac disease because of a
rogue chain of amino acids in some
people they are unable to break down
gluten the idea would be to design
proteins that act like gluten destroying
enzymes they would sit in a patient's
body awaiting the arrival of gluten and
as soon as the proteins meet it they
would chop it up and essentially digest
it doing the job done the patient's body
is meant to button celiac sufferers is
unable to do so the proteins would
digest the gluten
before it ever reaches the intestines
where it usually begins to wreak havoc
on the sufferers body but what if
designer proteins could be used to take
out cancer cells like tiny synthetic
terminators that's exactly what a team
at Stanford University School of
Medicine are currently working on the
persistent issue with all current cancer
treatments from radiotherapy to
chemotherapy is that they don't only
target and kill cancer cells they also
destroy healthy and important cells
during the process the extermination of
healthy cells causes some truly awful
side-effects for those undergoing the
treatment however Stanford University
are working on a project called razor
short for rewiring of aberrant signals
to effective
which aims to create synthetic proteins
now once inside the body could identify
cancerous cells and stop them from
causing further harm whilst leaving all
healthy cells intact the proteins will
be able to differentiate a cancer cell
from a normal cell because cancer cells
possess an always-on growth signal which
is why they continue to divide and grow
to form tumors long after a normal cell
would have ceased these proteins would
be able to target individual cancer
cells with remarkable precision once
found the proteins could latch onto the
cancer cells and rewire it which would
effectively redirect their incessant
grow signals towards a more useful and
healthy cause such as healing injuries
and repairing damaged tissue instead of
a nefarious tumor growth design any
proteins could also be used to diagnose
and check if a drug is working
effectively using Rosetta scientists
have been able to design synthetic
proteins that can bind to specific
molecules in the human body and when the
protein successfully binds it fluoresces
ie it lights up as can be seen in this
real-life microscope footage the
applications of this technology are
plentiful doctors could customize these
proteins to attach to cells and light up
if they detect the presence of certain
chemicals inside that cell those
chemicals could be drugs useful for
checking if doctor administered
medication is actually reaching the
intended cells alternatively they could
identify the presence of negative
chemicals in cells such as the various
carcinogenic chemicals including benzene
beryllium asbestos and arsenic which
could cause tumor growth or indicate the
presence of an existing tumor this
diagnosis ability will go far beyond any
techniques that doctors currently
possess and will be far more accurate by
using designer proteins cancer and other
ailments could be predicted in patients
years before the actual onset
of the disease whether you're a bio
scientist or a cupcake maker there's
only one place you should go to to build
a website for your business and promote
your brand Squarespace Squarespace
provides an effortlessly simple set of
online tools to craft your perfect
website in the way you desire I had a go
at building a website for 42 and I was
blown away by how quick and easy it was
the results looked modern stylish and
importantly unique to my needs and my
breath there are integrated blogging
tools to share stories photos videos and
updates which is ideal for regular
content creators such as myself if you
have an audience you want to stay in
touch with then Squarespace makes it a
breeze you can add social sharing
buttons to your site with a few clicks
you can run email campaigns to stay in
touch with your customer or contact list
like I've done you can also take
bookings and schedule through your
Squarespace sites and clients can easily
see your availability and reschedule if
needed
taking the hassle out of coordinating
calendars head over to Squarespace calm
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch go to Squarespace calm for
words last 42 save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain thanks
for watching subscribe for a new video
every week and thanks again to the
sponsor Squarespace don't forget to
check them out by using the link in the
description